[Music]
last month hackers breached gaming focus
blockchain platform ronin network an
ethereum compatible blockchain tailored
for the popular play to earn game
axionfinity the money stolen has been
valued at 600 million dollars making it
the second largest theft in crypto
history the hackers got away with 173
600 ether and 25 and a half million usdc
a digital asset pegged to the value of
the us dollar the u.s treasury
department has linked north korean
hacking group lazarus to this massive
theft
the lazarus cyber collective has
operated for more than 10 years with the
north korean government's blessing
gaining notoriety for its attack on sony
pictures in 2014 and an 81 million
dollar heist on the central bank of
bangladesh the group has managed to
launder 18 of the stolen funds as of
april 14th and continues to do so via
tornado cash a service that allows users
to obfuscate their digital trails
the hackers have been targeting crypto
entities since at least 2018 stealing
and laundering virtual currencies worth
in excess of 200 million dollars every
year a united nations report submitted
to the un security council sanctions
committee accused pyongyang of using
stolen funds from these attacks to
support its nuclear ballistic missiles
programs
until last year the majority of this
activity was directed towards
centralized cryptocurrency exchanges
located in south korea or elsewhere in
asia but in the past few months lazarus
has turned to decentralized financial
services like ronan by converting the
stolen cryptocurrencies at decentralized
exchanges the hackers avoided the
anti-money laundering and know your
customer checks performed at centralized
marketplaces and increasingly common
tactics seen in hacks of this type
blockchain intelligence firms including
chanalysis and elliptic continue their
investigations into the case ronan
announced they were working with
authorities and investigating the hack
on april 6 they also announced a 150
million dollar funding round led by
binance that will be used to reimburse
victims of the hack on friday the state
department's rewards for justice program
offered a reward of up to five million
dollars for information that would help
disrupt the flow of illicit funds to
north korea
[Music]
you